Chỉnh íc lối được bị tóm, vì sớm lò tết ất tị.
Qua nằm tình hình địa bàn, công an hệ đồ lương phát hiện lối tượng trận dây khánh,
sinh ngà một hình chỉ trăm chính mời, chú tại vệ đồ lương.
Có mìa viện gì vẫn mua bàn tra phét phép của các loại,
kế định theo dõi phạt tuy nhiệm chính cứ,
các quan công an rất liện, khánh hoạt động mua bàn tra phét phép,
bối linh qua đến địa bàn sạch hơn chính, khánh phối vinh,
nên công an hệ đồ lương, phối hậu với công an sạch hơn chính,
tóm lối tượng khánh về hành vi tàn chính hành cấm,
thu dữ hợp sống mới của bình, tổng trọng lượng là 1,000 kg,
qua đối trang khánh khai dạc mua sống mới của bình trên mạc để vệ bàn kếm lối.
Nghe hơi trên thẳng lời, các quan kệng sát đồ trà công an hệ đồ lương cho ai đã khởi tổ phụ an,
hởi tổ miệng cân đồ với tranh suy khánh về hành vi bộ bán hình.